are you doing pom rich I'm doing well I
seem to recall and although it wouldn't
have been the record Yogi Berra got the
pink slip less than 20 games into a
season late 80s Early 90s whenever it
was when George Steinbrenner was on a
firing spree yogi got the boot very very
early on so I have that I have that
number in 1985 16 games 1985 season in
that that was particular obviously I
mean to do that to yogi as well I mean
what what led to in yogi you have one of
the nicest human beings who ever lived
but he vowed never to return
to Yankee Stadium after that and Susan
Waldman who's one of the Yankees
announcers along with John sterling on
the radio side actually brokered a date
on tits right and Steinbrenner went to
the Berra museum in New Jersey to
personally apologize many many years
later and then yogi came back to Yankee
Stadium and a number eight and and all
the rest and it ended the way it should
have ended with with yogi back in the
Yankee fold but it's so ticked him off
and it took a lot to take Yogi Berra off
now as far as Brian price is concerned
today's news I don't know Brian price
well we haven't covered that many Reds
games on the MLB Network in person
because the Reds haven't been that good
but that's the answer to it you look at
the Reds roster in a perpetual
rebuilding situation he didn't have that
much to work with so I think he's a
victim just a you know you've got Joey
Votto and not much else he's a victim of
the material he had to work with and I
hope it doesn't it doesn't hamper him in
trying to land another big league job
somewhere down the road now I know this
may sound did you know pie-in-the-sky
but wasn't the new collective bargaining
agreement and how this is all working
out and baseball's supposed to do away
with so-called small market teams just
tapping out and just slicing payroll and
trying to make do we see what's going on
with the Marlins even though Derek
Jeter's come out and said that Mattingly
still needs to find ways to win games
but I mean weren't we supposed to do
away with the small market teams having
zero shot from the middle from April on
Bob yeah having zero shot uh I don't
think anyone ever believed that they
could get it to complete
equity but at least getting to a place
where teams had a shot and Kansas City
went to back-to-back World Series and
then following that you had a model that
a lot of teams are trying to emulate and
I don't know whether this is
Cincinnati's plan or not but it's
clearly the plan of some teams look at
the last two teams to win the World
Series the Cubs and the Astros each with
relative new-school thinking in their
front office new-school thinking that
now is becoming standard thinking and
the idea of these teams was why do we
want to go 75 and whatever adds up from
75 to 162 perpetually when we can just
tear this down get the draft choices get
the prospects that we get in return for
letting players go and if we play our
cards right we'll build a championship
team that's exactly what happened with
the O Epstein & Company in Chicago it's
exactly what happened under Jeff Lunas
direction in Houston and a lot of teams
rather than just be reasonably
competitive and somewhere around 500 are
following that model Bob Costas MLB
Network NBC Sports here on the Rich
Eisen show what do you think of Anthony
Rizzo saying that the schedule should be
shortened well I happen to agree with
him I think a 154 game schedule would
have historic continuity that's what it
was until 1961 in the American League
and 62 in the National League it would
provide some breathing room you have to
remember even when they were playing 162
games virtually every team played a
Sunday doubleheader hmm they played
double every week they played a Sunday
doubleheader they played double headers
on the fourth of July on Memorial Day
and on Labor Day that took care of some
of that bunching up of the schedule now
you have more teams in far-flung places
teams in Tampa and in Seattle you got
difficulties with travel they started
the season this year on March 29th a
record number of first month rain outs
and other games that were played under
arctic conditions it's not conducive to
baseball if you had a hundred and
fifty-four
it would provide more breathing room the
obvious counter-argument is that you
give up some revenue but I think there's
an answer to that what you'd be giving
up is for each team they'd be giving up
for home dates not all eight of those
games are home games obviously they're
there for home games for each team now
you are giving up some revenue because
almost all games are on regional sports
networks now so that's all eight of
those games would be regionally
televised so there is some revenue that
you would give up granted but the
quality of play would be better you
might have fewer players on the disabled
list and the way you make up some of
that revenue is you'd have enough
breathing room to intelligently expand
the playoffs without having it spill
into November everybody likes the one
game and out of the wild-card situation
but it's really not fair if the second
wild-card the lesser of all the
qualifiers has its ace rested and ready
if you're already locked into the second
wild-card and you have one really good
pitcher you can win that game and down
the drain goes the whole season of a
team that might have finished one game
back 100 games have finished one game
back in its division and took the first
wild card what makes more sense to me is
to play two out of three all three if
necessary on the home field of the
better of the two wild cards then what
you've done is you've created important
distinctions between finishing first and
being a wild card and between being the
first wild card and the second wild card
and then why should the first round of
the playoffs you didn't know you were
gonna get Treatise here but on the other
hand you booked me rich it's always a
possibility you go Bob Costas go down
this wormhole you keep going oh [ __ ]
okay
yes why logically out of three rounds
once you get past the wild card should
the first round the Division Series be
five games but the LCS on the world
series are each seven when the first
round is the one which by definition is
going to include the wild card and the
third best division winner now obviously
in a best-of-seven the best team doesn't
always win but when you play best of
five you're increasing the possibility
that the lesser team will win especially
because you've got off days between the
second and third game and the fourth and
the fifth that there is one which allows
you to manipulate your pitching if you
have two good starters in a way that
could never happen during the regular
season which further advantages a team
that might not be as good overall right
but which has a short-term shot so let's
suppose you expanded the division series
to seven games but you made the wildcard
best two out of three whoever survives
the wild-card has to abused by
definition two starting pitchers and the
way the modern game is played they've
got to go into their bullpen a little
bit
they will then travel to the home park
of the team that had the best record in
the league that team is rested and ready
not rested long enough to get rusty but
rested and ready enough even if they had
to go to the last weekend to clinch
their spot to get their pitching in
order further advantaging them
appropriately over the wild-card team
and then in that best-of-seven right
well the second and third best division
winners play a classic best of seven
which is 2 3 2 in this best-of-seven
between the wild-card survivor and the
best team you go to two three so five
six and seven if necessary are also on
the home field to the team with the best
record in the league so you've expanded
the playoffs yes by adding a second
wild-card which is better than having
just one wild card because when they had
just won there was almost no reason to
really care about who finished first as
long as you grabbed a wild card and so
many wild card teams went all the way to
win the world series that it proved that
it took a lot of the drama and the
meaning out of 162 games by having two
wild cards they've at least put a
premium on finishing first now you're
going to put a further premium on it and
you're going to further create an
appropriate hill to climb for not only
the first wild card but a larger hill to
climb for the second wild card not
impossible but appropriately difficult
now by having at least two and maybe
three wild card games that's additional
network
Kable revenue which is shared by all
teams by having the Division Series be
best-of-seven that's additional
television money which is shared by all
teams would it make up the entire amount
that you might lose by giving up eight
regular season games I'm not sure but I
think it would come reasonably close and
it would actually enhance the postseason
well making the regular season less
grueling for players fewer injuries
higher quality of play so can you start
from 154 game thinking because I just
missed that yeah so you haven't given
this any thought at all then Bob in
other words you haven't you know this
through I don't think you've thought
this through Bob this is what this is
what happens when you cut back on your
schedule and your time just to ruminate
right actually never to come on your
show again lesson until j.b smoove
joined me but I've violated that vow
several times since we got together at
the Super Bowls right that many many
years ago hey yeah we hooked you up with
Brooklyn Decker the last time to talk
about that did so we did take care of me
we've had good times on that front well
look that sounds like have you have you
posited that to any powers that be in
New York City I think I ran it by Rob
Manfred on one occasion and he politely
nodded and smiled by the way there are
people who believe no regardless of
whether it's inequitable in some
respects yes they love one gay man out
and I have to concede the fact that some
of these wild card games have been
incredible games in Oakland and Kansas
City a few years ago in Colorado in
Arizona last year they've been
incredible single games I grant you that
before I let you go Bob you were with
Hank you see the bum's rush pretty
quickly that my next man sir well one of
the volumes of the old Encyclopedia
Brittanica by the way no one has anymore
because you can google everything that's
true but back in the day it was actually
a sign of prestige for striving
middle-class families have
encyclopaedia britannica on the
bookshelf because it showed that they
cared about their children's future and
their education I had why the world book
in my house - hey the the Brock Meyer
conversation the Brock Meyer Musburger
feud that's going on right now Bob how
would you try to broker the peace here
between those two guys III think you
know Obama once famously had a beer
summit between the policeman and Henry
Louis Gates mm I think that Musburger
and Brock Meyer mm-hmm and it can't be
Hank Azaria it has to be just Rock Meyer
correct they need to meet not only over
a six-pack but a gigantic bowl of
tostitos and and hash this thing out
because it's gotten to the point where
fisticuffs may ensue it's gotten truly
nasty I see that Bert or rather the
Brent responded you didn't on on Twitter
yes today I'm concluded by referring to
Brock Meyer as a slime ball and there
was a veiled threat that one of his
Vegas enforcers might meet Brock Meyer
in the parking lot perhaps outside the
sands where I'm not sure who's appearing
it's probably Wayne Newton yeah around
some form of him back back in the day
could have been Shecky Greene is Lola
Falana which I would have preferred just
for just for the sense of absurdity that
would surround the situation all right
but I think that might be after we have
to get them together Bob you're no Brock
Meyer and as you know it's one of the
funniest shows on television agreed and
they screened the first episode of the
second season which premieres on April
25th last night in New York and there
were far I mean people laugh out loud
these aren't chuckles these are laugh
out loud lines it's a brilliantly
written show and Hank Azaria is just
fantastic as Brock buyer and as he told
you I saw his appearance with you there
are things that Brock Meyer can say once
you've established who this character is
but not only can't Hank Azaria say you
or I wouldn't even say his private
conversation but
rocked by her bra choir not only gets
away with it he thrives with it Bob
you're the best we'll chat again soon
please let me know when you're out here
in LA okay well hi red that's Bob Costas
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience